hello everybody and welcome to episode
number two of my f2p flipping series uh
we're going to go from 50 mil to 100 Mil
using only freeo playay items and we're
going to go mostly after high margin
expensive freeo playay items which there
are a few and uh we're going to leech
them for everything that they can uh
give so hope you guys are enjoying this
series and let's jump into it all right
guys so um if you remember last episode
we had some guilded chain bodies that we
just had to sell uh which they did sell
between so that's going to bring us up
to
56. 6 mil or something like that let's
just double
check um 56.4 so that's what we're
starting the episode at and uh right
before this we are about to head out um
for about two days to go visit my
girlfriend so I'm going to leave some
offers in now this is going to be a
little interesting so we're going to
start off I think with the guilded chain
body now I'm doing this because the
price seems to be quite low um down to
400 and you can see over the last month
it's pretty much an all-time low used to
be up to a mill almost so I think we're
going to put an offer in for quite a few
of these and uh hopefully we can
actually buy them while we're gone
because we did just sell them for 700 so
that's a pretty good margin just on its
own so
gilded chain
body going to go for four
25k and uh we're going to go for
30 uh no clue if I actually buy all
these or not but uh we can always hope
next up is uh the team Cape ey you can
see here it has a 100 100K margin on it
roughly and uh seems to be pretty steady
here so I think it'll be pretty safe buy
so we're going to buy him for
1435 and 14 35k and we'll go for 10 sure
next up is the team Cape X um going to
try buying it for
3950 and uh hope maybe it gets up here
by the time we get back who knows it
looks like it's been trending upwards
for a while so maybe it'll continue
maybe not but either way I don't think
we lose too much team Cape
zero and we're looking at about
[Music]
3950 and we'll go
for five of these yeah sure five and
lastly I think we're going to try the
iron plate legs they have dropped quite
a bit guess since raids came out uh
we're up to 700 now down
to 200 or 250 I can't even get that 260
and if we go back even further uh we can
see they're probably at an alltime low
so I'm hoping that they start to raise
up because otherwise we're going to lose
a bit on this uh but we're only gone for
two days so it won't be too bad so 250
is what it looks like we can buy them
for iron plate legs
G 251k
and we're just going to go for a amount
just use the rest of our money 35 maybe
and there we go guys so we'll see how
many of these Buy in the two days I'm
gone I'm pretty confident uh that we'll
at least hopefully make some money on
this and we'll check pack in a couple
days all right guys we're back from our
two-day vacation and interestingly
enough none of the guilded chain bodies
uh bought but we did get quite a few of
the rest of our items so uh let's pull
them out so we'll start with the team
cape I so we bought them for
1435 and um let's open up G tracker
here um looks like we might get 100K
maybe on them
1528 uh so we'll try to sell them for
that uh now we're selling them for 7 mil
uh
635k and we bought them for 7
m175 uh so not too bad 500k pretty
decent next up the team Cape zero we
bought all five of those all right so
the team Cape zero is up around 4 mil
looks like uh 4 4050 maybe and we bought
them for 39 60 uh so another 100K almost
on each of those so we're going to sell
them for 40
49k uh the ACT trade price does seem to
be quite a bit lower um but uh yeah
we'll go for 449 sure and that's going
to be a 500K profit not
bad and last up we got quite a few of
these iron plate legs uh for 251 now
we'll have to check if we can actually
sell those for a profit cuz we did
continue to get them iron plate legs all
right we got the iron plate legs open
here and uh hopefully we could sell them
for 295 that would be amazing yeah let's
go for 295 they've been up there for
almost all day just now that they've
lowered down a bit uh yeah
294 294k that would give us uh 6.4 mil
we're selling for and we bought them for
5.5 so that's nearly a millon profit
pretty nice uh so we'll let these sell
and we'll come back uh hopefully when
they fall sold all right so we've have
successfully sold off all the team Cape
eyes uh we were getting uh 92k on each
of them uh so selling five of those off
gives us about 4960k in profit so not
bad and uh we're still in the progress
of selling off the rest of our items um
we're going to reevaluate their cost
because um it we leave these in offers
in for a while like that was a day and a
half almost
so I mean like they haven't sold at that
point they probably have changed in
prices so we'll go ahead and recheck
this all right so we bought the plate
legs for 251 and um they're kind of low
down right now but uh we're willing to
take a break even maybe on the rest of
these unfortunately all right so the
gild two-hander looks like it has a
pretty decent margin on it about three
uh 3.3 mil into uh 3 370 or something so
like 70k uh which is pretty good good
for a free to- playay item to be honest
uh so we'll put an offer in for maybe I
don't know 10 yeah sure we'll go for 10
and last up the monk robe looks like it
has a pretty decent margin as normal uh
buying them for 6650 and we maybe sell
them for 6900 which would be about 250k
in profit uh which is good that means
that I don't think we can afford two uh
so we'll just have to buy the one but um
you 250k is 250k so we'll put an
offering for 6650 and uh yeah we'll back
when these offers have
completed okay so unfortunately uh these
flips weren't very good uh we broke even
on the iron play legs and we broke even
on the team Gap zeros now we have bought
five of these gilded two-handers for
about uh 3301 uh which is pretty good so
hopefully we can sell them for uh the
3480 and we also did sell to the monks
robe top G's and that's going to be for
13796 and we bought them for 13330
it's a nice uh 500k profit so pretty
happy with that all right we're going to
try buying a couple more of these rope
tops uh they spiked quite a bit last
night uh but we'll try buying them for
66 6 6680 would probably be good uh go
buy another
two
6685 and we'll go for actually go for
four how about and for the last item
here we'll probably try the hill giant
club lookss like it goes down to about
1220 or uh 1222 and sells for about 1260
if we get 10 of those pretty easily
that' be about 400 500k so pretty good
and uh we're going to buy it for
1222 and do 10 of those and I think
we're going to call that a day okay
we'll come back when these have sold all
right guys so we had a moderate success
on uh most of the items the uh Hill
giant clubs only got an 18K margin and
we only got four of those that's only
72k uh the guilded two-handers though we
did get a 46k margin and four of those
got us
184k uh the monks robe we are not done
selling but each one we're getting about
200k uh so that's 400k in total so
pretty good and uh we'll we'll make sure
we have the right price for the monks
robe and then go find a couple new items
and uh first up I think we're going to
do the iron trim Set uh looks like it's
a pretty decent margin and these do
trade a lot so we'll go for 20 and even
if we get the 20 or 30k margin that that
will add up to quite a bit of money now
looks like the monks row bottom gold has
a 100K margin on it and while these do
take a long time to buy 100K on a two
Mill item is pretty good uh so we'll go
ahead and buy maybe uh four of these for
now and then move on to another item it
looks like the team Cape ey is actually
at a pretty big low point for the day so
we'll go ahead and P offr for like 1402
and maybe we'll catch a 50 60k margin on
it maybe even 100K we get lucky uh but
we'll go for I don't know six just a
random number pretty well but a lot of
stuff I Do Is Random pretty much and uh
now we're going to do a little bit of a
different item here I noticed I went
onto the high volume tab of GE tracker
and uh when you're on the f2p mode of
course only show freet to-play items and
soft clay actually had a really good
margin on it surprisingly look I can't
even sell it for 112 now I'm not sure if
I'll be able to buy a full buy limits
worth of the item uh because it'll
probably change quickly but look at that
111 into 129 that is insane for a high
volume item so we'll see how much we can
snag at the 111 price uh before it
undoubtedly raises up some more uh 112
and 10K I don't know if we're actually
going to get this margin or not um but
yeah we'll see how many we manage to buy
of the soft clay and then maybe find out
one more item and I think for the last
item we're going to go with the monks
robe top G again uh just has the biggest
margin on it usually and uh we kind of
were looking for quite a while we had
nothing really to do with 18 mil uh so
we'll go ahead and put an offer in for
I guess just two of these and yeah we'll
come back when all these items have sold
all right guys we're back and
unfortunately we only got 1.5k of the
clay if we had gotten all 10K we would
have probably got like half a mil in
profit but that being said we still got
50k uh the team Cape eyes we got a 47k
margin on giving us about 282k in total
uh the monks robe top uh G's were kind
of sold in two different parts a little
messy but in total we got 420 2K just
went back and checked and the iron
trimmed armor we got a 40K margin on
three of those giving us about 120k so
not to shabby uh about 700 800k on those
items and uh yeah we'll go ahead we're
probably going to leave the monks Ro
Bottoms in for that price hopefully
they'll sell and we'll find a couple new
items so surprise surprise we're going
back to the monks robe top uh but it's
just quite a bit lower than normally is
so it's in there for 6.6 mil and uh yeah
we'll do
go for five of these maybe next up the
Gilded two-hander looks to have a pretty
good margin look how much it swings back
and forth uh so we could buy for 3.3 mil
roughly maybe a bit less we could get
maybe 100 or 150k margin on it uh which
would be pretty nice we'll maybe try
buying it for 3275 or something and uh
we go for maybe four or five of the
swords as well and go for three and uh
the guilded armor set is always pretty
good right now it looks like a 70k
merging on it but uh this is one of the
items that actually does come through
pretty quickly uh so 70k would be pretty
decent I mean if you consider I invested
all my money into this that would be 10
or 12 of those we give us about 800k in
profit unfortunately right now we're
just going to go for two I guess uh and
we'll put the offer in for maybe 4305
yeah looks good and uh we'll go for two
all right guys we'll come back when
these items have sold and maybe wrap up
the episode all right guys so we finally
got everything to actually sell at once
um and the two Anders we did manage to
get all 10 of them we did sell them in
two different parts at the first part we
got three of them sold for 74k margin
giving us 222k in profit uh the second
part was for a 65k margin and the rest
of them uh was for
455k the Rope bottoms we only got a 38k
margin giving us about 152k in total
from that and the guilded armor we only
got a 53k margin on so about 106k in
total from that uh so everything is sold
and it looks like we're up to 60 mil
plus uh so we'll go ahead and check uh
our cash T to see what we're actually at
so 60.1 mil so we gotten about 10 mil in
profit off the two episodes so far so
I'm pretty excited uh hopefully we can
do even better next episode and I hope
you guys are enjoying the freeto playay
flipping content if you are don't forget
to leave the video a like and uh I will
see you guys in the next episode
n
[Music]